مليون و600 الف حاله تسمم غذائي يوميا
بسبب تناول الاطعمه ملوثه اي ان المتوسط
في
المتوسط الثانوي للاصابات 600 مليون حاله
رقم كبير كبير جدا ارقام صادمه مشاهدينا
لفتاه اليها الامم المتحده في اليوم
العالمي لسلامه الاغذيه والذي حمل شعار
معايير الغذاء تنقذ الارواح في عالم ما
تكتظ فيه السوق بالاطعمه المعباه
والمعالجه فان قراءه ملصقات الطعام امر في
غايه الاهميه رموز واشكال لا نعطيها
اهتماما لكن الاطباء وخبراء التغذيه
ينصحونك بعدم الاستخفاف بها نظرا الى
المعلومات المهمه التي يمكن الحصول عليها
عن المنتج لميس ستطلعن سريعا على ابرز
واهم هذه الرموز
والمنتجات الغذائيه اللي موجوده عليها فكي
لنا طلاسم الرموز يا لميس
خبيره بالرموز ما هي هذه الرموز والاشارات
على المنتجات الغذائيه التي يجب ان لا
نستخف بها ابرزها حرف e اي ان المنتج
يحتوي على مواد حافظه مصنعه ولها اثار
صحيه رمز الثلج على الاطعمه يدل على وجوب
حفظه دوما في الثلاجه حتى لا يفسد او يسبب
حالات تسمم غذائي الطعام الخالي من المواد
المعادله جينيا وهي جي ام او فري اي دون
مواد كيماويه وهو من الاطعمه الصديقه
للبيئه علامه خالي من الجلوتون للاشخاص
الذين يعانون من حساسيه الجلوتين اشاره
خالي من السكر خاصه بالاشخاص الذين يخدعون
للحميه الغذائيه ولمرضى السكر ايضا اما
علامه الرمز الاخضر اي المنتج نباتي خالي
من اي مكون حيوان المصدر امر مهم
للنباتيين
اخر الرمز سي اي يدل على ان المنتج مطابق
للمواصفات الاوروبيه ومعايير السلامه
ومتطلبات حمايه البيئه
عادل عامل اضراب اليوم طيب معنا في
الاستوديو مشاهد المهندسه الغذائيه لما
النائلي اهلا وسهلا فيك اهلا وسهلا
كيف الصحه اهلا وسهلا
رموز
ومكونات غريبه عجيبه
لاي شيء نشتريه لازم بالضبط كيف بدنا نفك
رموزها هيك شو اهم اشي لازم ننتبه عليه
اكثر شيء ممكن يؤثر على صحتنا طبعا لازم
نعطي الملصق الغذائي
نحن عم نتسوق غذائيا لحتى حافظ على صحتنا
كتير سؤال حلو شو اكثر شيء اذا ما كان عنا
وقت كتير بالسوبر ماركت نقراه كرمال نتاكد
المنتج الغذائي اللي نحن عم نتسوق ولنا
ولعائلتنا ولاولادنا امن صحيا وامن غذائيا
بالبدايه بدنا نقول في عنا دائما عم نلاقي
حرف الاي على الملصق الغذائي هذا دليل على
وجود ماده ملونه او ماده حسب الرقم يلي
موجود ضمن
بجانب الحرف على المنتج الغذائي كل ما
كانت اقل عدد
المضافات الغذائيه والمواد الحافظه اللي
هي بتبتدا باي مثل اي 102 124 كلمه هدول
المنتجات كان المنتج اكثر صحه واكثر عافيه
بنروح لايضا كل ما كانت المواد الموجوده
ضمن المنتج اقل على سبيل المثال اذا بدنا
نشتري علبه بسكويت اذا كان قمح بيض ماء
السكر مواد نحن بنعرفها كمستهلك هيك نحن
معناتها هذا
يعني منتج جيد نوعا ما اما اذا لقينا
بقلبه مثلا غريبه اسماء ملصق فيها كلمه
شغلات غريبه على المستهلك نحاول نتجنب
هالمنتج لانه بيكون في نسبه كبيره من
الموا حافظه وايضا الملح اللي له اسماء
مختلفه نحن بغينا عنه هناك من يقول بان
نسبه المواد الحافظه لا تؤثر لكن في بعض
الاسامي احنا ما نعرفها
فلوريد ما بعرف ايش
نسرين
الاسامي ما انزل الله بها من سلطان ما راح
نعرف هي شنو كرمال هيك نحن بدنا نقول
على اللابات والاغذيه الموجوده لكن كل ما
قللنا من استهلاكها بالمنتج الغذائي اللي
نحن عم نتسوق وعلى بيتنا كل ما حافظنا
اكثر على استدامه صحتنا وصحه عائلتنا
وعززنا من عافيتنا كرمال هيك نحن ما بنقدر
نتجنب كومبليت طيب
خلينا ناخذ بعض الامثله مثلا معروف بانه
الدهون المهدرجه والمشبعه شيء سيء جدا
صحيح بس بكونوش كاتبين لنا دهون مهدرجه
ودهون موهين شوي صح
كتير حلو السؤال بدنا نمسك
الملصق الغذائي ونقرا فيه اذا كان اعلى
شيء مكتوب ساتوري
الدهون المتحوله والدهون المهدرجه لازم
حكما ما نشتريه اما اذا كان يوجد فقط
مكتوب
يعني الدهون الدهون لها انواع الدهون من
الزبده الحيوانيه على سبيل دهون حيوانيه
افضل من الدهون النباتيه لمى سريعا احنا
خلصنا لكن خلينا يقول شنو اللي ما نشتريه
ما نقرب له اللي مكتوب عليه الاغذيه
الملونه جدا بعض الالوان
الملونات الملونات كل ما كان في الملونات
حتى مكتوب الملونات الصناعيه حرف الاي اذا
اكثر من اربعه اربع احرف اي ضمن المنتج
جنب تشتري المنتج اكثر من اربعه في المنتج
لمى النائلي تقول لكم
طبيعيه افضل من الدهون النباتيه المصنعه
الزيت المهدرج مضر جدا العوده للزبده
الحيوانيه والسمنه الحيوانيه اكثر صحه
بكميات قليله
خروف
الحياه سعيده
لما تقول بكميه قليله وفق الهندسه
الغذائيه احنا نقول اكل
واحبس بشاي يلا
هنا لك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات